depuis 2017 et son arrivée au psg les
français n'ont qu'un mot à la bouche
celui de neymar neymar que ce soit pour
vanter les mérites olympique de ce
champion brésilien superstar du football
payez pas moins de 3 millions soixante
mille euros par mois ou pour critiquer
ces dérapages et sa fragilité comme
faut-il faire pour que neymar est de se
blesser voilà que faut-il faire pour
choyer naïma un comportement qui agace
même si sur le terrain les bars
impressionne
s'il est une star sur le terrain il est
aussi un people scrutent et en dehors et
ses dérapages font la une de l'actualité
comme cette accusation de viol d'une
jeune mannequin dans un hôtel parisien
en mai 2019 contre je suis accusé de
viol une affaire aujourd'hui classée
sans suite
autre polémique celle de ses vacances
mouvementées à ibiza cet été durant
lesquelles le joueur n'aurait pas pris
toutes les précautions et aurait
contracté le coronavirus avait faire la
fête à ibiza c'est clairement pas la
meilleure façon de se reposer ils sont
libres ils ont le droit mais au moins
revenait en forme les gars hier soir
neymar était au coeur de toutes les
attentions sur le terrain dans les
gradins comme sur les réseaux sociaux
son nom était une fois encore partout
approché alors qu'ils dansent quart
d'heure sans fil tu sais encore neymar
voilà connais bien mais est-ce que hier
il était victime ou coupable
on va tout vous dire on va tout vous
raconter est ce que c'est vrai ce qu'on
a entendu hier et surtout merci olivier
tallaron d'être là parce que vous étiez
vous êtes journaliste et consultant pour
canal+ est excellent ça fait des années
que le suisse olivier il va nous dire
parce qu'il était au bord du terrain
donc il va nous dire il va nous dire
exactement ce qui s'est passé vous avez
tous d info ici on aura rené malleville
plateau et demain mais qui sera là en
duplex dans un instant et qui va nous
dire exactement aussi alors pour revenir
sur toutes les polémiques y est on vous
montre le seul but du match mais on vous
explique aussi pourquoi ce n'est pas du
tout le côté sportif que ce match voilà
de noces au match a fait parler pour un
autre côté aujourd'hui la question c'est
beaucoup beaucoup de monde se pose c'est
le football est il devenu trop violent
vous avez fameux petit récapitulatif de
tout ce qui s'est passé hier je sais
qu'un a beaucoup qui ont regardé le
match mais malheureusement j'ai pas la
chaîne je suis canal+ à fond regardez
c'est un véritable événement qui s'est
déroulé hier soir au parc des princes à
paris entre le psg et l'olympique de
marseille
un clasico sous haute tension qui s'est
conclu par une victoire de marseille 1
but à 0 une performance qui ne s'était
pas produite depuis neuf ans il faudra
attendre
30e minute de jeu pour que la
malédiction marseillaise se brise avec
un but signé florian thauvin pour l'om
mais en dehors de ce but on était en
droit de se demander s'il s'agissait
d'un match de foot ou d'un match de boxe
et ont cette fois ci la violence et la
tension était présente sur le terrain ce
qui se passe insultes bagarres crachats
carton rouge il était plutôt question
d'un affrontement entre hommes qu'une
compétition entre joueurs
résultat une pluie de sanctions et un
match qui s'est terminé à 8 contre 9
avec notamment l'exclusion de neymar et
côté supporters l'ambiance n'était pas
tellement meilleures entre insultes
affrontements banderole sexiste et
homophobe
difficile de parler d'esprit sportif
selon lui le foot est il devenu trop
violent alors ce qui est elle plus
parler aujourd'hui sont donc les
insultes racistes qu'aurait tenus le
joueur marseillais alvaro gonzalez à
l'encontre de neymar le brésilien a
accusé à plusieurs reprises le défenseur
espagnol de racisme se peignant
d'ailleurs auprès de l'arbitré le
problème c'est que les images diffusées
permettent de voir neymar se plaindre
mais pas les insultes mais nous on a la
réponse ce soir regardez là bas
[Applaudissements]
l'assistant
alors olivier merci d'être là vous étiez
hors du terrain alors comment vous avez
senti le truc et on dira d'ailleurs
puisqu'on a été voir un petit peu et on
a essayé de disséquer ce qui s'est dit
exactement on a à peu près deux
solutions à ce qu'elle m'a dit voilà
gonzalez vous allez voir dans un instant
vous olivier mine de rien ce qu'ont
assisté c'est un des matches les plus
violents de ces dernières années on a vu
un neymar très énervé dès le début oui
oui dès le début c'est il ya plusieurs
choses dans ce match d'abord vous dites
que c'est un des 1 des plastiques au les
plus violents de ces dernières années
moi je suis belge et allez on va dire
depuis presque 25 ans ça fait 20 ans que
j'ai pas vu un clasico aussi aussi tendu
bagarre générale hier franchement tous
les gens qui étaient au parc ça que
benjamin aussi lit tout le monde était
choqué franchement l'arrêt à l'image de
ce qu'on a vu
neymar était très énervé tout le match
on peut on peut reprendre un petit peu
ce qui s'est passé 1
tout vient aussi de en partie du
chambrage de dimitri payet après la
finale de la ligue des champions qui a
beaucoup remonté les joueurs parisiens
et c'est vrai que tout part d'un petit
peu de la mois de source sûre je sais
qu'il y avait plusieurs joueurs du psg
qui qui souhaitait entre guillemets se
faire dimitri payet pendant ce match et
c'est peut-être aussi pour ça que et
neymar et paredes quand il est rentré et
bien on pétait un peu les plombs alors
on va revenir sur ce qui s'y était dit
parce que ce dont tout le monde a parlé
aujourd'hui même ceux qui ne
s'intéressent pas du tout foot vallée
riche débat d'intérêt c'est pas du tout
vous avez tous entendu cette histoire
qu'est ce qui s'est passé entre neymar
est ce joueur marseillais
alors on va revenir sur ce qui s'est
passé et on va vous donner les infos
faut savoir qu'en conférence de presse
après le match l'entraîneur marseillais
un bébé à andreas sand et andré
villas-boas s'est exprimé mais sans dire
ce qui s'était exactement passé
aujourd'hui je pense qu'on est capable
de dire à peu près ce qui s'est passé
puisque on a pu voir et lire sur les
lèvres voilà tout ce qui s'est passé
mais regardez ce qu'a dit l'entraîneur
c'est pas m arrêter un peu une rue avec
situation j'espère qu'on n'a rien n'à
pas j'espère que ça va pas m
dieu noir de cette victoire je pense pas
parce qu'on va vous un jour express
expérimenté il a évidemment il a pas de
place pour le racisme dans le foot mais
je pense pas que c'était le cas alors
neymar ici énormément plein je vous le
dis sur twitter il a même fait un laissé
un message à 4 heures du matin tu n'es
pas homme assume et on erreur perdre
fait partie du sport mais insulter
ramener le racisme dans nos vies non je
ne suis pas d'accord je ne te respecte
pas tu n'as pas de caractère assume ce
que tu dis mon vieux soit un homme mec
raciste gilles verdez alors des imams
toute la nuit
il a poussé très légitime c'est la star
poussé la direction du psg est allé très
loin dans cette affaire
le problème du psg c'est qu'il n'y a pas
pour le moment d'image irréfutable on
entend les mots toute la journée le psg
a cherché neymar a dit mais trouvé
trouvé il m'a dit ça neymar il a déjà
perdu des matches il n'a jamais crié au
racisme comme ça qui s'est passé quelque
chose et pourquoi le psg soutien mais
marre parce que neymar dit que c'est
inacceptable
et si le racisme est prouvé c'est le
règlement c'est l'article 9 du règlement
le joueur marseillais alvaro pouvoir dix
matches de suspension c'est ce qu'ils
veulent albarède dix matches de
suspension et s'ils ne sont pas prouvés
ces agissements racistes mais marc lui
c'est irréel mais lui peut être condamné
pour sa brutalité son expulsion
regardez on a derrière à dix matches de
suspension comportement raciste et cyril
pour compléter ce que dit
gilles c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui la
commission de discipline a réclamé les
images aux diffuseurs et demain à 15
heures a assuré qu'il ne pouvait pas
appuyer les propos de neymar parce qu'il
ya à l'heure actuelle en tout cas
aucune image prouvant qu'il a vraiment
me porte alors oui j'aime ça être assise
porte plainte je ne montre rien mais
dites-moi olivier il me semble que c'est
à la 38e minute très certainement oui
d'accord que soit disant peut-être
présomption d'innocence
alvaro aurait insulté neymar mais on
peut dire quand même que avant cette
38ème minute de la zéro à la 37e minute
neymar a été épouvantable en dessous
tout la montagne c'est ce que le gardeur
oui c'est ce que neymar n'est maritime
qu'il fasse on était très très chaud
avant le match remontent et donc par le
chambrage de payet entre autres c'est
pas excusable mais mais c'est vrai qu'il
a été très nerveux et il a dégoupillé
vraiment un moment très précis du mal
vous dites la 38e minute lorsqu'il a
entendu alvaro prononcé donc selon lui
des propos racistes alors effectivement
de gilles le deed il ne s'est jamais
plaint sur un terrain de propos racistes
donc na il a l'air assez bizarre quand
même d'aller loin oui mais voilà la
phrase môme l'a dit voilà c'est ça c'est
vrai elle est terrible c'est fdp de
saint jean webb a dit me séparer de plus
de 100 d'accord oui c'est ce que c'est
et la pression oui ça serait du
médiateur au mahdi la présumée c'est
vrai qu'au bâton il y avait alvaro idée
tout le temps derrière lui et on voyait
très bien qu'ils le disent des choses
qui étaient des atouts le temps donc
effectivement parler foot là qui en est
à une autre polémique voilà parce qu'on
va faire les deux en même temps il a dit
maria aussi la star argentine du psg qui
aurait craché sur alvaro gonzalez
ça c'est vrai qu'en ce moment surtout
avec le colis des ces choses à nous dire
ce qui peut ce qui risque et ça vraiment
il ya beaucoup de gens aussi qui ont dit
que ça c'est s étaient unanimes même si
di maria normalement que c'est un joueur
vraiment calme complet regarder voilà
c'est assez rapide en bas la maison
décrypter les images et encore une fois
les images ne montrent pas de crachats
insultes on a pas d'image qui montre le
crash
ça va devenir compliqué la donne car on
entend plein de choses hein j'entends on
parle d' insulte raciste moi pour moi il
n'y a pas de racisme à partir du moment
où les lèvres ont été décortiquées et
qu'on ne voit rien l'appareil le crash à
vous par les crachats soit pas crash à
rennes
une hypocrisie monstre sur le match
d'hier soir je termine simplement vip on
sait comme moi je pense qu'on a retrouvé
dans le match hier soir et ça peut faire
hurler je peux l'entendre le sel des
vrai clasico des années 90 elle est loin
commissions passaient pas le sait ces
attentions
mais justement on a retrouvé de
l'engagement c'était quartier contre
quartier c'était des deux côtés et je
pense qu'il ya plein de gens qui ont
joué comme moi devant le match bonjour
indoor et oui qui ont adoré regarder
match hier soir il y avait plus école
prochain clasico vous donner la date
olivier l'espèce de morale qui dit qu'il
faut trouver ça honteux la vérité c'est
que ça fait des années qu'on dit quand
est ce qu'on va retrouver les vraies
castilla qu'un dont on a retrouvé de
l'engagement dans la gare go non mais tu
peux quand même des limites hier sur la
fin de match
sincèrement vous avez beau vous avez vu
beaucoup tes vous allez pas me fait à un
certain moment d'attaquer au clavier
mais il a raison les enfants ont quitté
et là on va parler il avait un peu qu on
va parler d'exemple parce que apprendre
à la réaction de rené molle qu'on
attende vraiment et a failli à tous tes
seins grant est un grand joueur de city
celui-là il avait 45 kg de moi je vais
vous dire il tombera de nom mais j'étais
triste hier parce que l'aïeul contexte
les marseillais sont venus ici pour
faire dégoupiller les parisiens il ya le
chambrage de payet olivier l'a dit ils
sont tombés dans le piège et j'étais
triste de voir ces enfants gâtés alors
vous allez me dire des mots combien de
ces enfants gâtés milliardaire qui se
prennent pour des voyous c'est des
imbéciles ils savent pas se bagarrer
vous aider je vais pas vous insulter ça
sert à rien mais l'image on l'a on vous
donne on vous donne l'occasion de créer
un spectacle pour faire rêver tout le
monde pour être à la hauteur
on vous donne un million par mois et
cetera et cetera vous donne des fortunes
pour vous cracher dessus pendent covin
pour vous insultez des propos racistes
mois pour moi un clasico francesca la
joie
moi j'ai pas joué parce que faut jamais
oublier on n'a pas vu
c'est tout ce qu'il faut à la télé le
dimanche matin les gamins le samedi
matin
refonte traitement si toi tu veux voir
des cas de sico comme ça moi je veux pas
voir des clasico comme ça ou quand tu va
emmener ton fils
il va cracher parce que son idole c'est
di maria ou il va insulter raciste parce
que son idole seine-et-marne voit ses
envies moi j'ai envie d'autre chose et
que tous tes infos ici moi je veux pas
qu'on fasse les langues de bois et il y
aura rodez malvy dans un instant il sera
pas langue de bois dit la vérité de ce
que vous savez des infos que vous avez
on a tous et des infos est ce qu'il ya
eu insulte aux racistes ou pas bien sûr
on reste dans le monde
la présomption gilles verdez oui
franchement il y avait quelque chose
c'est pas possible autrement
la manière dont ils marchent comporte
bien sûr il n'est pas exemplaire
toujours mais là la manière dont il
devient fou c'est la folie quand vous
êtes traité d'une manière raciste c'est
sûr c'est pour ça qu'il est 2010 comme
ce qui s'était passé avec zidane n'était
pas raciste parce que neymar
ils risquent sept matches de suspension
pour brutalité or d'action 5 rue va être
suspendu donc ce qu'est ou non pour moi
c'est honteux
l'injure a également aidé mars et
l'attitude de jérôme brizard qui est l
arbitre hier on fait beaucoup tombent
sur cet arbitre un défaut il faut pas du
tout excuser les joueurs comme vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure sont
inexcusables hier tous les joueurs qui
sont battus qui s'il ya eu des insultes
même neymar a pas été irréprochable
pendant pendant ce match
mais le pg a reproché à jérôme brizard
de ne pas être à l'écouté de neymar
lorsque plusieurs fois il lui a dit j'ai
eu des propos racistes intervenez j'ai
eu des propos racistes intervenez jérôme
brizard c'est une petite polémique parce
que c'est un jeune arbitre et le pg a
demandé pourquoi il avait été désigné
pour ce match plutôt qu'un arbitre jean
michel oui je peux pas te cautionner
franchissions peut pas se réjouir qu' il
ya une violence qui anime un clasico que
ça fait le sel du foot as ma tutrice
jouer ici que les supporters se tapent
dessus en dehors du stade
je tenais d'avoir déjà vu des morts dans
ce genre de cas est carrément ya eu des
grosses embrouilles occupation et
raymond ta tunique cc ils sont payés les
milliardaires et abc jetant l'argent qui
pervertissent et l'argent qui crée la
violence sur les stades à ce camp les
joueurs touchent des primes de plusieurs
dizaines voire par faire plusieurs
centaines de millions d'euros quand ils
gagnent le match qu'est ce qu'on fait
mais on trouve les thomas maps et on les
taxis chronologiquement il faut
physiquement toujours gagner le match
face aux argentins
on va se remettre en question mon cher
on est des vedettes on est des stars on
est l'idole des jeunes
il faut on a une image à véhiculer le
club aussi doit aussi parler à ses
joueurs parce qu'on parle d'institutions
que ce soit pg ou marseille on parle
d'association
lanig aussi doit faire les choses parce
que maintenant le foot il est filmé et
c'est en vidéo
moi je veux bien je veux bien mais j'ai
jamais vu cristiano ronaldo lionel messi
ou des grands joueurs en europe ce jour
faune et moi comme des baltringues
jamais j'ai vu hier ils sont peut-être
jamais fait non plus via la selo fait
partie du temps et jean-michel ya pas
que jean-michel dit la vérité est ce qu
a votre avis il ya eu un bien sûr
insultes bien bien sûr on peut reprocher
beaucoup de choses à l'ema qui simule
parfait et cetera mais c'est pas
quelqu'un qui fabule comme ça et dice
éprouvée dans les derniers dernière
affaire malheureusement assez sulfureuse
que dont il était l'objet
s'il a dit ça ne l'a pas inventé le
tronc s'est passé ils y gagnent
suffisamment gens ils sont fous hyper
n'y perde ça change pas ça ils s'en
foutent pas tant alors oui un truc
vraiment moi je suis parti à rené
malleville 1 kg n'a rien comme toi mais
non il ya plein de gens qui disaient
depuis dix ans on se met tellement
intéressant les classiques ou espace
rien si oui et là effectivement alors
est ce qui s'est passé il forge est fort
c'est bon ça c'est pas bien mais restons
sur ce qui s'est passé juste pas dire
s'il a beau match ou pas c passable ce
que je vais vous dire c'est que par
rapport aux prosélytes est ce que le
football est trop violent
je vous dis non effectivement là il
s'est passé des choses qui sont graves
mais on va remettre en cause tout le
football est effectivement fayçal on m'a
dit c'est le seul regret que j'ai c'est
de ne pas avoir frappé ce trou du cul au
visage oui ce trou du cul j'aime bien
c'est beau
[Rires]
voilà qu'on me parle je me reconnais
dans ce trou du cul
je suis est ce que c'est trop violent il
ya plein de gens qui ont dit comme
raymond message je vois plein de
réactions sur les réseaux sociaux qui
disent ils ont tout pour être heureux
pourquoi ils font ça
il doit faire rêver les gens est ce que
valérie et n'est rien en football
oui bon c'est la légère mais là il faut
pas connaître le pouls de bauzon sont
des fans de football donc ils sont voilà
il regarde et je sais quoi que mais que
votre fils mon beau fils mon mec mon
fils est aussi ils ont deux patios les
boeufs et le foot voilà en l'occurrence
me venait de montrer quelque chose dans
la la colère est retombée la colère
aurait pu retomber langue là par exemple
et tweets de neymar c'est après le match
joué à entendre déjà chaud quand on est
insulté quand il s'agit de racisme et
c'est qu'on ne maîtrise plus et que là
on oublie on oublie le footballeur qu'on
est l'exemple pour doit être etc
mais une fois qu'on est rentré dans le
vestiaire une fois que les instances
dirigeantes nous ont parlé une fois que
etc puisque la faire ensuite va être
justement me sont à table peut-être
judiciariser peut-être que les instances
vont prendre à ce moment là tu
redescends tu écris un tweet en disant
ce qui s'est passé je trouve que c'est
inadmissible et et donc il y aura des
sanctions qui s'imposent parce que le
racisme c'est mal et s'est battu très
pâle alors jusqu'au voilà je sultan
savoir sens et olivier talent olivier
taux qui sait tous comment ça va se
passer maintenant y avoir une enquête
serrée de quoi parole contre parole
commission discipline d'abord demain
pour tous les joueurs qui ont été exclus
en a cinq
alors évidemment on va voir parce que
bagarre générale regardez les prix ils
regardent et bagarre générale
[Applaudissements]
quand ça va mal se terminer ça
terminer parce que paredes
tapez 1 on
bon c'est une accentuation
évident de la réaction du joueur
marseillais qui a été frappé
catastrophe la passion
ce qui se passe
alors je vous le dis regardez c'est vrai
que ça a chauffé avant le match entre
les supporters aussi entre les joueurs
aussi et regardez il y avait même une
banderole regarder devant la tour eiffel
om on est en beau ça s'était passé
n'était pas ça voilà non mais la
banderole devant la tour eiffel psg om 9
ans voit la sodomie en bande organisée
c'est vrai que ça c'est fou regarder la
banderole qui avait été une bombe
l'envoyait d'ailleurs hier à dix essais
comme putney sain et c'est vrai que ça a
chauffé les cinq la journée ça fait rire
dans le public un voilà et c'est vrai
que c'est ça aussi nommé qui fait que
quand ils sont rentrés sur le terrain ça
a été très chaud des cires olivier oui
donc juste commission de discipline
demain c'est parole contre parole a dit
pardon mercredi c'est commission
discipline pour les cinq joueurs qui ont
réussi un carton rouge donc ça c'est
assez classique encore à neymar
sanctionnant puisqu'il a reçu un carton
exactement et puis pour l'histoire
d'alvaro et neymar une éventuelle insus
insultes racistes et bien là ni peut
décider la commission discipline peut
décider d'instruire la sphère de
regarder les images
la ligue a les images en sa possession
et pourra décider si insultes avérait de
de sanctionner le joueur et s'il y en a
pas peut-être alors le mans neymar en
tirez vous parler des réseaux sociaux il
ya la réponse de pédiatres quand même
aujourd'hui ciation alors qu'est ce
qu'il a dit dimitri payet lauréat sur
instagram il a posté une photo alors
bande organisée visiblement c'est un
groupe de rap marseillais en bande
organisée s'est pas la capitale ouais
marseille mais bo1 sur carros et le sait
le sait le plus le type qui cartonne en
ce moment et donc alvaro qui portent
neymar
marseille qui cartonne alors juste
olivier oui vous qui était au bord du
terrain dit la vérité est ce que vous
pensez que neymar dit vrai ou est-ce que
vous pensez que neymar a mal entendu où
il s'est trompé il faut être très
prudent
cyril parce que on peut pas être on peux
pas être affirmatif totalement sur ce
genre de choses
moi personnellement j'étais au bord de
la pelouse j'ai pas entendu cette
insulte d'accord là il faut se fier à ce
que dit neymar pour autre côté du psg et
l'om se fier à ce qu'a dit alvaro c'est
parole contre parole
si une image qui prouve qu'ils prouvent
l'insulté bien voilà c'est pas gagné
mais on peut pas aujourd'hui être
affirmatif alors on va voir on va voir
rené malleville et vous allez réagir
également rené auque est avec nous ce
soir ça le relais bah tu vas le voir
demain sur le plateau mais là
rené est ce que déjà qu'est-ce que
quelle est ta réaction toi parce que tu
dois être content parce qu'ils ont gagné
mais il ya cette polémique est ce que tu
penses que neymar dit vrai ou est ce que
tu penses que c'est c'est pas c'est pas
vrai qu'alvaro lui a pas dit ça
d'ailleurs vous des coûts tels
d'halluciner pourquoi d'abord le plus
gros bide joueurs prennent gesca plus je
prenais avec qui on a vécu des matelas
marbella me prat gaye après la femme est
alors là t'es pas là pour pécho
ce qui s'est passé la mort et tu paies
choix après alors à l'origine rené
pureté des poids de chemin depuis tout à
l'heure ça l'uci pourquoi parce que bon
j'ai le l'avantagé ou l'inconvénient
d'avoir cet état jada j'ai vécu des
clasico à bagages manière le clasico
à côté de ce que j'ai vécu dans les
années 90 c'est le défilé de majorettes
d'accord alors tu es d'accord avec pang
jusqu'à et sur ce qui s'est passé hier
qu'elle suppose de néma mai mais moi
quand on voit un masque aux molières
avec l'intensité les l'ale contacts
qu'il a eus on regarde je ne recherchais
pas si la victime à paris comme samba ly
que tu m'a pourri que ce que dit le mari
non mais relève tu déjà plus que
marseille a gagné et camus le communiqué
c'est toi qui a été envoyé aux pertes
0,1 mais a justifié les bras de l'ema
ouais donc pas alors voilà alors d'autre
que toi qu'est ce tu m'as réveilles tu
peux tu peux cautionner un match comme
ça c'est passé c'est un exemple pour les
uns tournée les jeunes sakhir ghana le
match assez serré il tirait c'est mon
coude ah oui oui
la parfois la vie de l'espace capelle
maria ou pour une loi de la ministre des
sports oui au fois qu'elle voit elle
n'était jamais allé à et stable la
ministre des sports et la nuit quelqu'un
qui verrait 4e david duré huit années
elle est sortie
pourquoi pas d'une vitalité même jérémy
laffont même jérémie janot gardien de
but il a dit le questeur à cause du r
moi à marseille
chaque fois ml de ça tu fais ta femme
est trop bref ils avaient été
comptabilisées aux séries ma femme est
jamais à l'avancé et ils le savent très
bien aujourd'hui dans ta démarche qui de
marionnettes phase i am very big joueurs
de roide mal être qui un jour en jour
monde cm cuite à l'eau ronaldo il a une
prestance
il fait plein de trucs en europe et
l'hygiène de vie extraordinaire voilà
parce que ce jour que je dois tu te
plateau en place il parle il démarre en
parler de démarches qui visent à la fête
le problème puis l'été de tous les
joueurs il fallait marquer mais ni marcy
de marionnettes regarde mes mains après
7,3 et les membres de l'aappma milieu du
cinéma
[Rires]
non parce que les pizzas sicoval c'était
à six coups y avait des ordres face il y
avait des erreurs cash attendait l'avion
vinolas étaient pourtant parisien il
nous a dit il a dit dans l'interview
nous annonce n'est pas encore scellé
martin gray tombeur sans lever dit alan
gala du mathématicien mme royal très
bien en tout cas tu étais content qu'ils
aient gagné l'om gilera
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
violet la seule chose que disent les
gens c est ce qu il a regardé le match
sk
parce que là
granby qui serait un coup de main bien
sûr alors d'avoir la vidéo ou neymar 3
son carton rouge
regarde ça regarde le cartos de neymar
garde oui en tant qu'organe pas
carton
[Musique]
alors c'est vrai qu'on a essayé on voit
quand même
le joueur lui par lewis le dîner marc
depuis ce matin au club c'est il demande
au club bien sûr de l'aider mais
pourquoi pas quelqu'un qui puisse lire
sur les lèvres c'est ça parce que ça a
été fait en football alors est ce qui
sort dans ce qu'on a vu c'est un peu ce
qu'avait dit voilà trois mois peut-être
on n'a pas de certitudes
non voilà est ce qu'il faut une preuve
irréfutable vous dise exactement de
parole c'est le problème n'est ce que
c'est ce que ça suffit ça quelqu'un qui
lit sur les lèvres
olivier nass et leur travail c'est à la
commission de discipline que de juger
mais à l'heure actuelle encore une fois
on le répète au vu des images
il n'y a pas
il n'y a pas de doute sur voilà sur les
sur ce qu'a pu dire en tout cas le var
où il n'ya pas d'insultés racistes sur
ce qu'est ce qu'il a dit est de 20 ans
le joueur qu'est ce qu'il a répondu à
néma après il a répondu qu'il fallait
accepter de perdre parfois qu'ils ont
perdu leurs nerfs qu' il n'y a jamais eu
de racisme
il n'a jamais eu des propos racistes
s'il a eu un petit incident il ya
quelques saisons avec messi messi en
lisant tes tout petit et messi lui a dit
toi tu es nul au foot voilà alvaro c'est
pas quelqu'un d'irréprochable on m'a dit
il parle beaucoup
neymar aussi mais puissent pas loin mais
alors alvaro on ne peut pas lui
reprocher d'être assis s'il a jamais eu
de propos racistes de tête rieurs mais
c'est pas alors on avait aussi qu'il
faisait partie d'une a dit qu'il avait
twitté il a fait partie d'une année
faisait partie d'une association il ya
aussi contre le racisme etc
donc il dit je vois pas pourquoi on me
reproche à raymond voulais rajouter leur
non moi je disais que c'est dommage tout
ce qu'on a vu hier et c'est dommage
parce que quantic anti s'insulter font
tous sous leur cinéma la halle est
fausse bagarre à deux balles là moi je
pour dire que neymar pour moi c'est le
troisième joueur meilleur du monde c'est
le meilleur joueur du monde en numéro 3
le talent il n'ya pas le constater je
préfère neymar qui joue au football et
qui s'expriment balle au pied qui face à
tout à l'heure et après on a fait voir
un tweet toi tu es un homme tu es un
homme et lui met une claque dans le dos
de dos illumine claque par derrière tous
ces trucs là j'aime pas parce que toutes
les banderoles que vous avez vu vous
avez vu des banderoles où l'on aime et
riou nous allécher les insultes qu'est
ce qui se passe après les vrais
supporters et on a vu des drames gilles
type témoigné olivier peut témoigner
on a connu des drames par le passé où
les mecs ici ils vont pas en vacances on
sent bien sûr les joueurs aimeraient ils
vont en vacances ensemble et ils sont
sur paris dans les plus grandes boîtes
de nuit ça il faut le dire
marseillais et parisiens ils se tirent
la bourre avec des meufs place al autour
d'eux y'a pas de problème mais les vrais
gens ils se battent à coups de barre de
fer après c'est ça qui m'énerve moi
c'est cette hypocrisie de faire semblant
de se cracher dessus je te pousse tu me
pousse à ta vu je suis un show ans t'as
vu je t'ai dis ça je te remets claques
dans le dos et si t'es un homme mais
vous n'êtes pas des hommes
vous êtes des enfants gâtés millionnaire
donnez nous le spectacle qu'on attend
nous on veut juste qu'il fait on veut
tiff est impérial regardez à claouey
sont des roulades et bien que samedi le
dimanche sur les terrains nus en
banlieue tu vas voir si c'est des
petites claques c'est des vrais droite
score jamais
[Applaudissements]
je
la vraie vie on n'est pas technique mais
il ya quatre gardes du corps avaient
tenté il passe par me font rêver mais la
plupart des joueurs du psg de l'om sont
des amours de meutes au vent voilà je
les adore les joueurs du psg marque
innocent un ami cher enfin benzema à
chaque fois que je rencontre c'est un
super mec vous l'aimez bien aussi et
pembe voulait l'adorent elle adore c'est
une bande de mecs et laisse jamais eu un
souci au carré tonneau dire voilà tous
les joueurs sont dire les joueurs et
nous font rêver moi je suis désolé le
psg fait rêver qui peinent bente rêver
et je l'adoré c'est bien
qu'exceptionnels ville de rabat voilà il
ne fait pas toujours rêver elle voit la
balle aurait des six pôles et dans les
quartiers je pense abbaoui champagne
ardenne match a vu ce que fait paris en
plus je vous dise
c'est facile de tomber sur les marchés
moi je vous le dirai en plus moi je veux
pas d'histoires parce que un joueur du
psg est mon voisin lequel il avait eu
dans le même immeuble que moi non
c'est le gardien remplaçant rico ouais
j'ai pensé qu'il m
c'est pas qu'une aire de boxer bonzou
bernède moi moi je dis four soir là
merci d'être là on peut pas en rester là
syrie parce que là ok il ya des
polémiques sur le match mais on voit la
photo d'alvaro là ils sont que la ligue
puisse nous dire s'ils allaient ça
surtout pour nous le dire parce que là
ça va je suis prêt à faire une foule va
suivre la sphère arabe sonora les infos
demain et la ligue aussi alors je vous
direz vous savez j'adore une info vous
savez pourquoi en fait j'ai tout tout
tout ce qu'on tout concorde apparemment
doc gynéco est en train d'enquêter c'est
pour ça que sera la 2 avec tout ce que
la plus longue
oui d'ailleurs rayon pourquoi elle
samedi soir et des matchs sur canal bien
sûr le match samedi soir vous livrions
samedi à laval monaco nice monaco très
bon match merci genre à la fouillade le
sondage nourdine assez mon chéri non
acquis 58 % oui à 42 cents